nutritionists reveal humans with proper
diet should Katie what I know we're
facing scary times right now but I
thought it's time for us to let it loose
for a little bit and have a little fun
instead of reacting to our usual memes I
decided to react to some of the
headlines and articles from the onion
for those of you who don't know the
onion is a satirical newspaper none of
their headlines or articles are true so
I hope to get a good laugh
don't get offended it's comedy we're
here to have a good time you ready
excited patient points out organ he
wants from kidney tank in spittle lobby
how dirty to read the article look at
the little kid be floating badass
surgeon puts on fingerless late excludes
me for operating the dirtiest meeting
the most infectious full of bacteria and
viruses part of your hand are the finger
tips dr. Scholl's introduces new Freeza
wait o remover oh I have this thing I've
actually used it cuz I had a wait it got
me
Chicago foot care brand dr. Scholl's
unveiled its freezer wait over for
Thursday and over the counter treatment
that combines fries therapy with
fast-acting liquid to loosen and
ultimately expel unsightly totes not
gonna lie my toes are looking rather
rough during this pandemic struggle is
real I'm self pedicure not good at it
the real product that the onion is doing
a witty satire of is actually a fries
away treatment for plantar warts if this
specific treatment thing he doesn't work
for you at home we have one where we do
this cryotherapy in our offices I wonder
if anyone like clicked on this and
they're like ooh that toe was getting in
the way health insurance CEO reveals key
to company's success is not paying for
customers without the cook care just the
other day I had a patient i prescribed
them a medicine for a common antibiotic
send it into the pharmacy pharmacy has
insurance not paying for him like what
it's like one of the most common
antibiotics
get on the phone spend half an hour
arguing to insurance company and what do
they tell me oh it's because you ordered
the capsule version not the tablets if
you just ordered the tablets it would
have been fine you only half hour of my
life back tips for finding the right
just by the photo I'm already excited
for this tip ask yourself what your
personal goals are when you see a doctor
people on a limb or die do you want to
prevent illnesses or contract them the
goal is to live and the goal is to have
the least amount of illness possible
doctors can provide better care when
they treat your whole family so try to
get the same primary care physician for
your spouse children and pets
I was gonna say this is a good one and
then they do in pets a skilled physician
should be able to detect any potential
health problems so never tip them off by
revealing any know we need your help the
history is probably the most important
part of the exam with the physical being
the second most important I guess it
depends on the illness I'm trying to
diagnose ask them straight up if they've
ever killed a patient on purpose hey doc
you ever did that to a patient
tell your doctor your fid knee hurts a
good one will know that that's not a
real organ
a good one will know what you mean no no
a good one will know to ask what you
meant without such sounding judgmental
other patients can be your best allies
when it comes to finding the right
doctor agreed ask friends and co-workers
if you can sit in physical to get a feel
for what their doctor is like hit by a
bus make sure they have kind eyes that
crinkle at the corners when they smile
does your doctor have crow's feet that
means they care many health care
professionals are increasingly rigid
when it comes to prescribing medications
remind your doctor that with a couple of
bad online reviews so you can bring it
all crumbling down man this is so true
people that run their own businesses
they're between a rock and a hard place
but patient comes in requesting a
specific treatment or a specific test
and the doctor doesn't think it's in the
patient's best interest but the patient
threatens them with the bad review what
do you left to do and you know what the
worst part is let's say the patient
leaves a fraudulent negative review says
the doctor did so-and-so and the doctor
knows it's untrue they can't go on and
say that because of HIPAA patient
privacy above all don't put too much
pressure on yourself
you meet the right doctor when you're
ready that's like a dating life no in
all seriousness it's really important to
find the right doctor because if you
have a healthy dog
to patient relationship you're more
likely to have better health outcomes
and if the first one isn't right always
look for a second opinion I'm in witness
protection
I mean doctor I work at doctor says
neighbor I'm in witness protection
I mean doctor I work at doctor says new
neighbor
anybody twelve seconds later okay I need
to do better
grandfather's accidentally switched in
yet another disturbing case of hospital
negligence two elderly grandfather's
were accidentally switched at Cedar
Mount Sinai Medical Center in Los
Angeles and sent home with the wrong
families I think this is poking fun at
the fact that back in a day people may
have taken the wrong babies home but
nowadays we have a lot of security
around taking the right baby home moms
and dads get security bracelets that if
the babies approaching one of the exit
doors they won't open unless the father
or mother have also their security
bracelets on so no one's taking the
wrong baby home nor are they stealing
one but the elderly that's funny Russell
Westbrook quietly asks rockets team
doctor if he needs to make free throw to
pass physical why is he so bad at free
throws
he's like 70% that's pretty bad
nutritionists reveal humans with proper
diet should Katie what pooping is great
urinating great are they're unhealthy
poops yes are they're unhealthy urines
urinations yes that's a question for you
doctor you know what I'm worried about
an article like this gaining traction
unlike an Alex Jones podcast and then
people being like oh man and here I have
been for 45 years pooping my whole life
what have I been eating doctor asks
patient if he would mind having medical
students some of his poker buddies in a
room for exam if you've never had this
happen to you before I bring in a
medical student or a resident with me
when I see a patient I always ask for
permission it's the right thing to do
it's the plain thing to do and actually
I think there's rules for it now how
funny would it be here
dr. Watson is like can I have a medical
student like sure yeah what about some
poker buddies and the people that they
put in the guy with the glasses so I
used to play poker semi-professionally
back in the day when there was Full Tilt
ultimate bad absolute poker poker stars
all those good times I don't understand
why peewee people and they play live
poker they wear dark reflective glasses
it's like they want you to see their
cards u.s. dentists can't make nation's
teeth and he did whiter you know there's
like something that happens
internationally where they actually make
fun of Americans for having two white
teeth they actually make it a joke to
say all you Americans with your white
teeth I do think that we go overboard
when people do veneers and stuff they
bleach their teeth white like porcelain
but sometimes it's too white like it
looks artificial I will say that if you
over bleach your teeth it will make your
teeth sensitive and it will hurt so
please be careful this has happened to
my friends tap it to myself when I was
younger made the mistake not happening
again
exhausted doctor to wake up early finish
Serge in morning just moments after
successfully stopping his patients hard
at 10:30 p.m. Tuesday bleary-eyed
surgeon dr. Dennis Kelly called it a
night and decided to finish performing
quadruple bypass surgery on Harold
Cruise 67 in the morning honestly all
these organs are looking the same to me
right now said Kelly this is actually a
legit struggle some surgeries go on for
hours pretty much the entire day that is
why we have teams of surgeons and
surgical residents that help out in
specific operations in addition to that
we always have a backup surgeon on call
in case the surgeon starts feeling
unwell get sleepy ER doctor excitedly
tells wife he got to use shock paddle
thing today
the picture of the doctor I've been
wanting to play with those thingies
since my first day and I finally got to
I put them on the guy's chest yelled
clear and they went just like they do on
TV called a defibrillator we have to
start this segment this way chest
compressions chest compressions chest
compressions you don't run for the
defibrillator until you start doing
chest compressions first after of course
you call for help but you can call for
help while you're doing chest
compressions the reason we do chest
compressions because you need to buy
time for the defibrillator to get there
to turn that on to make sure it's
working all that good stuff health scare
prompts man
to start over eating healthier I love
that as it sounds that's a giant plate
of food it looks healthy but there's a
lot of it this has been a real wake-up
call for me so from now on I'm sticking
to eating only nutritious low fat foods
well past the point of being full it's
not how it works
if you enjoyed this video I know you're
gonna enjoy my medical meme review
series click here for that playlist or
if you want to see me argue with doctor
house m.d. click here for that one which
one you're gonna click while you stay
happy and healthy
[Music]